ich habe höhenangst ok sehr gut und ich
habe auch schon mehrfach auf solche
compilations reagiert wo leute irgendwie
ein parcours machen auf hochhäusern und
keine ahnung was aber er wollte das
unbedingt nochmal sehen von daher
stürzte ich mich wieder in ein meer
voller meiner angst keine ahnung was
hier gerade passiert er läuft nach vorne
und er verschwindet plötzlich okay also
ich glaube er wollte nur zeigen wie hoch
diese treppe ist der läuft ja jetzt
nicht
[Musik]
das ist so wie ich springen kann und er
läuft alle drei meter treppe hoch das
ist jetzt allerdings noch alles nicht so
krass höhenangst krass mäßig sondern
laufen einfach nur irgendwelche wände
hoch also ich bin gespannt wo das 1
[Musik]
nicht dabei auch für österreich laufen
alter ich kriege direkt gänsehaut wenn
ich hier so nah über an an so
hochhäusern und dann laufen die darüber
okay das geht jetzt hier gerade noch
einmal guck mal nach rechts oder links
das ist die sind auf hunderten dabei ist
denn deren ernst aber was er bei könnt
ihr nicht normal joggen gehen irgendwo
im park oder so könnt ihr auch über
parkbank im springen müssen
oh mein gott da musst du nur einmal
abrutscht
ich trau mich nicht mal ein hochhaus
hochzufahren
das abgesichert ist und mit dem
fahrstuhl hochfahren uns und die
springen da einfach drüber ich checke
nicht was der sinn daran ist kummer auch
hier wenn ich doch nur einmal abrutschen
dann fallen direkt über 100 meter runter
und sind einfach droht also kleid sagt
du jetzt wahrscheinlich oder leute die
das gern machen sagen jetzt
wahrscheinlich aha adrenalin und keine
ahnung war es aber ich kriege adrenalin
auch wenn ich vor neun spiele becker
zeigt ihr am arsch
sei
jetzt machen also klar er muss sagen es
sieht schon cool aus wie die da
irgendwie so rüber springen und ist ein
krasser aufnahmen also das ist könnte
auch ein grund sein warum man das macht
aber so lebensmüder für aufnahmen
das
können wir bitte den nächsten clip rein
rollen also hier geht es jetzt gerade
weiter ich bin noch mal raus wirklich im
ernst als check solche leute nicht auch
er okay er hat da unten einen pool und
er springt vom dach runter das sind doch
eh sie fünf meter in so einen kleinen
pool mit einer höhe von einem meter da
muss doch jedem bewusst sein dass man
das nicht machen sollte aber so wie er
steht und mr
neben körper
36 halt wirklich nicht da ist schon
wieder eine person auf einem dach ist
dass der gleiche ist
das sieht nach einem ähnlichen hause aus
es ist nicht er springt auch in
ich habe mich früher nicht mehr getraut
vom beckenrand
zu springen also ich verstehe es
wirklich nicht auch das hier jetzt
people and saints comeback er steht auf
was sich jetzt also mein gott ich habe
den text klingt es ist halt nicht mal
irgendwie normaler kran gerade gewesen
sondern diese ngo mein gott hatten gibt
es schon
h
was ist so schwer daran einfach nicht
solle scheiße zu machen ich glaube das
ist dubai hier gerade wo die sind und
dass sie den dänen hatten wir den hatten
wir schon mal
der immer das ist
einmal einmal
ich habe heute morgen die wasserflasche
in der hand goldring und wie ist die aus
der hand gibt und der macht da seine
komische grenzen an diesem gerät das wir
sind jetzt wieder irgendwelche parcours
a
er springt über
und er steht auf einem blatt was habt
ihr davon
mir fällt nicht ein als er steht auf
irgendeinem komischen masten irgendwie
drauf auf seinem sicherungs dings ich
glaube dass sie das wirkt auf dem video
nicht ganz so krass hoch aber es ist
meter hoch die beiden jungs hat mir auf
dem fall auch schon mal dass wir irgend
wo in der ukraine oder in russland oder
irgendwo so und die steht nicht der
moment moment ich geh mal 50 und zurück
da hat er sitzt dort und ich denke
wenigstens nach hinten leider nach es
ist ein
was
ist
falsch mit dear reader talk wenn da ein
ganz kurzer windstoß kommt dann fliegt
er einfach runter und das sieht jetzt
auch nicht gerade im 50 meter lauf
sondern erst nach 500 metern sah das aus
er steht auf einer brücke aber da muss
man wenigstens euro mein gott
data einmal ich erzähle ich
ich kriegte ich gleich die formkrise ich
krieg dich vor krise ich stehe hier mit
gänsehaut und schweiß an stellen an
denen ich nicht mal wusste dass da
schweiz kommen kann
ich habe gesagt ich rede da heute drauf
also weiter geht's hier ist wieder
irgendein verrückter in abu dhabi oder
in dubai oder keine ahnung wurde den
hatten wir schon mal der rollt sich dann
nämlich ja genau der macht selbst noch
so kurze bäumen runter es doch komplett
wahnsinnig das ist doch spätestens da
muss jedoch bewusst werden jetzt sollte
ich mal
schaut ihn euch an wie er das schild
ne
mir fällt dazu nichts ein ausser dass es
einfach lebensmüde ist kinder macht das
nicht nach okay ich glaube nicht dass
einer so dumm wäre und auf dem hochhaus
gehen würde und sich da aber macht es
nicht nachkommen nicht auf diese idee
weiter geht es mit dem nächsten clip den
hatten wir auch schon mal dass es
irgendwie ich weiß nicht warum man auf
die idee kommt sowas zu bauen irgendwie
offenen hochhaus obendrauf hat es bringt
ja augenscheinlich wirklich absolut gar
nichts dass jetzt wieder ein typ auf
einem gerade das ist halt bei cez hält
ist heute rund da kannst du so schnell
abrutschen
also bei einem hochhaus das ist
wenigstens eine ebene fläche weißt wo du
drüber läuft und weiß okay egal wie ich
laufe ich bin auf einer ebenen fläche
avantgarde aid ist ja ganz andere liga
von lebensmüder also er läuft hier
weiter bei seinen komischen kran rüber
stellt sich jetzt vorne an die spitze
sowie der titanic das sind auch oft
entwickle ich immer die gleichen leute
ich bin froh dass wir jetzt hier so ein
bisschen wieder parcours sehen weil wenn
der da irgendwie abrutscht dann bricht
er sich vielleicht irgendwie nahm oder
irgendwie so aber solche leute wenn die
abruzzen sind einfach tot oder auch er
ich meine die haben wenigstens noch so
ein ding da zum festhalten aber auch er
hier
ich versteh's nicht verfällt sie
darunter sondern wir es nur von autos
überfahren ich verstehe es wirklich
nicht leute weil ihnen jemand von euch
irgendwie parcours macht oder keine
ahnung was ist sehr schön und gut
ich hatte mal so einen parcours kurs
fand ich auch super war aber in der
sporthalle von unserem gymnasium und das
war halt entspannte dann ist man
irgendwie die wände hoch geklettert und
hat derzeit groß gemacht und keine
ahnung was aber weiter auf dem euro raus
oder auf einem kran und auf der brücke
mein gott kommt klar vorleben alter ihr
habt nur eins sagt er da noch nicht
einfach nur lang laufen können sondern
die comedy müssten dann auch noch
irgendwie drüber springen noch ein salto
machen er hierher muss erstmal raum
springen sich aber im kreis drehen dass
sie gar nicht so nah doch kommen
[Musik]
absolut gar nichts mehr zu ein ich
verstehe es wirklich nicht freunde da
hängen leute irgendwie vom kran runter
den er hat mir gerade schon so wenn er
glück hat fällt herunter und fällt ins
wasser daneben
er steht
[Musik]
moment das war der 2
nebenberuflich wie kommst du denn
überhaupt dahin weil die lassen dich ja
auch nicht hoch so du musst du ja
erstmal einbrechen also es ist ja nicht
nur illegal in dem sinne dass sie sich
da aufhalten sondern auch wie dahin
kommen oder keine ahnung was und jetzt
jetzt haben ein mädel das schaffen
toll
das verstehe ich jetzt kann ich sogar
das sind leute die springen über
hochhäuser die ketten an kränen rum die
laufen überbrücken die machen parcours
über wohnhäuser 100 metern hören dann
ist ein mädel geschafft
das ist ja mega krass fand allerdings
wieder zurück zum wesentlichen meine
lieben freunde und zwar den lebensmüden
menschen hier oben ist sogar so eine
rote lampe die hängen abhängen also
meine definition davon ist ein bisschen
chillen mit freunden aufs sofa bei denen
ist abhängen glaube ich hatte ein
bisschen eine andere bedeutung wir sind
gleich fertig mit dem video meine lieben
freunde also keine sorge krass einfach
aus die hängen dazu zwei therme
er macht auch noch er macht sport darum
ich kann mir das nicht geben guck mal
der er hält sich nicht mal fest der
läuft einfach über punkt einfach
es tut mir leid
beschwert sich dann immer darüber hey
luca wie kannst du dir die ganze zeit
pausieren blabla system eine reaktion
auf die leute wenn ihr euch das video an
sich anschauen wollt dann schaut euch
das video so aber es ist ja meine aktion
meine kommentare darauf was ich gerade
hier zu sagen wollte zu dieser person
hierüber lang schaut euch das an hat
hierfür ein wind ist schon mal ein
bisschen zurück dass ihr das nochmal
sehen achtet mal auf die rose dies haben
wir weiter wie die da im wind weht
ist ja nicht so dass man da nämlich nach
sporthalle ist und dann irgendwie man
einen balken läuft und da ist kein wind
war zeit eine abgetrennte halle habe
keine ahnung was ist sondern sehr frei
in hunderten metern höhe
[Musik]